OK.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a caller who seems to think Trump is
going to prison.
Would you vote for Morgan?
Go, go.
Come on.
I love your show tonight.
As always, enjoy your show.
But you were stealing that.
There's no way Donald Trump would ever go
to jail.
If we actually have a free and fair election.
And Joe Biden is elected, there's only three
ways.
The.
The fact that Trump never goes to jail.
OK, one the interim president spends.
Pardons zoom to Biden pulls on Obama and Gozo.
We're looking forward to about two or three
during all the legal wrangling, he actually
passed way over the only three ways that Donald
Trump does not go to jail for all the crimes
that before his presidency.
During the campaign and during his presidency.
I just respectfully disagree that the United
States is not the type of country where former
presidents go to prison.
And I'm not arguing that Trump has not done
things that would put a normal person in prison.
That is not my argument.
My argument is merely Trump is not going to
prison.
That that's my prediction.
Maybe I'll be wrong.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Don't miss it.
Grab a membership.
Join Patman dot com.
You will be provided instant access to the
bonus show.